GOOD
MORNING WELCOME TO OUR
REGULARLY SCHEDULED BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR TUESDAY APRIL
TWENTIETH THE CHAIR RECOGNIZES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM BUT
ALSO MEMBERS OF THE REPUBLICAN-
COMMITTEE AS WELL SO WILL BEGIN
AS A SUB COMMITTEE JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS- PLEASE BE
REMINDED THAT WE ARE
MAINTAINING SOCIAL DISTANCING
FOR THOSE WITNESSES WISHING TO
DIAL IN FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 ACCESS CODE IS.
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN AGAIN IT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS
WELL AS- ON YOUR TELEVISION
SCREEN. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
CALL THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE FOR IF NOT FEEL FREE TO
CALL OUR COMMITTEE OFFICE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
THREE THREE ZERO ONE. BECAUSE
THEY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS
AND- BECAUSE WE'RE ACTING AS A
SUB COMMITTEE WILL GET TO-
ITEMS ON CONSENT IN THE- NEAR
FUTURE. SO BECAUSE WITHIN- GO
INTO FILE ORDER. AND WILL EGIN
THEN WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
FILE ITEM ONE IS. SUGGESTED FOR
CONSENT BUBBLE GOING TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO AS OUR AUTHORS
HERE THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY ONE. BY A SEVEN MEMBER
CHAO. ASSEMBLY CHILD THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE AB
YOU'RE ACTING AS A SEVEN TWENTY
BUT PLEASE FEEL FREE 2%
WHATEVER READY WELCOME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- EIGHTY SIX NINE ONE
WOULD ENSURE THAT OPTOMETRISTS
ARE AUTHORIZED TO ADMINISTER
CLI A ALL CLEAR WAVED CULVER
NINETEEN TESTS AND COVER
NINETEEN VACCINES IN AN EFFORT
TO HELP IDENTIFY AND STOP THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS. THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AS OF
APRIL FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HAVE BEEN. A THREE POINT
SIX MILLION CONFIRMED CASES OF
CULVER NNETEEN IN CALIFORNIA
RESULTING IN FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND PLUS DOUBTS. THE
QUICKEST WAY TO GET OUR STATE
BACK TO NORMAL IS TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES TO THE POPULATION.
CURRENT LAW AUTHORIZES
IMMUNIZATIONS WITH A CERTIFIED
OPTOMETRISTS TO ADMINISTER
THREE VACCINES FOR THOSE
EIGHTEEN OR OLDER WHICH
INCLUDE. INFLUENZA HERPES
ZOSTER VIRUS AND ALSO NEED A
CAUCUS CLINICAL LABORATORY
IMPROVEMENT AMENDMENTS OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT CLEARER
RECENTLY WAIVED POINT OF CARE
TEST FOR COVER NINETEEN. WHILE
ATOMIC TRYSTS ARE AUTHORIZED TO
ADMINISTER CLEAR WE'VE TELL US
THEY ARE RESTRICTED TO
CONDITIONS OF THE I. EIGHTY SIX
NINE ONE WOULD ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND A NUMBER OF WAYS
FIRST IT AUTHORIZES OF TIME
TRYS. TO APPLY TO THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF THE ATOMIC
TREE WHEN IMMUNIZATION
CERTIFICATE TO ADMINISTER A
PASAR C. O. V. INTO VACCINE.
SECOND IT WOULD ESTABLISH THE
SUBSTANCE OF AN APPLICATION
FORM FOR THE IMMUNIZATION
CERTIFICATE AND EXPAND THE
CERTIFICATE TO COVER THE
ADMINISTRATION OF IMMUNIZATION
FOR S. A. R. C. O. V. TO.
VACCINE FOR IT ALSO AUTHORIZES
OF THOMAS PEOPLE MAKE WAY
CLINIC AFTER TEST YES TO DEFEAT.
TO WHAT THE TECH PRESS OF SARS
C. O. V. TWO I HAVE RACHEL
BLEACHER ON BEHALF OF MY
SPONSOR THE CALIFORNIA CONTRAS-
ASSOCIATION AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS A MEMBER CHAO WILL
NOW OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES AGAIN THIS IS FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
PRIMARY WIN THIS. PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER READY.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RACHEL. WITH
NIELSEN MARKET MARKET THE
FLYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION. THIS BILL AT THE
CLICK CLICK LANGUAGE THE
OPTOMETRY PRACTICE ACTIVE
PERMIT OPTOMETRISTS TO
ADMINISTER THE COPA NINETY
EIGHTEEN VACCINE AND COBIT
NINETEEN CLEO WADE TAX.
OPTOMETRISTS ARE TRAINED
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS TO
ATTENDED FOUR YEARS OF GRADUATE
SCHOOL TO OBTAIN A DOCTOR OF
OPTOMETRY. UNDER CURRENT LAW
OPTOMETRIST MAN MINISTER OTHER
VACCINES AND PERFORM TO CLEAR
AWAY TAX OR CONDITIONS OF THE
I. HOWEVER BECAUSE THE
OPTOMETRY PRACTICE ACT NARROWLY
TAILORED LANGUAGE ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGES NECESSARY TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT UP CONSCIOUS ARE
ALSO ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
VACCINATION. AND CLEAR AWAY
PATH FOR COVERT NINETEEN. AT
THE STATE RESPONSE TO THE CALL
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC EVOLVES
AND NEW TAXES ARE APPROVED BY
THE FDA. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
THE LAW CLEARLY STATES THAT
OPTOMETRIST MAY PROVIDE THE
SERVICES. THE FDA ANNOUNCED IN
MID MARCH BUDGET IS DEVELOPING
A STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION FOR
TRAINING TAX. STATING THAT
TESTING REMAINS AN IMPORTANT
CORNERSTONE OF OUR NATION'S
FIGHT AGAINST COVERT NINETEEN.
AT HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
THAT ROUTINELY ADMINISTER OTHER
VACCINATIONS AND CLEAR WAY
PAST. ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE
TRAINED ON PROPER TECHNIQUE AND
PROVIDE SERVICES IN ACCORDANCE
WITH FDA. CDC AND CMS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND GUIDELINES.
THEIR SERVICES WILL BE LIMITED
TO VACCINATIONS AND CLEAR AWAY
TAXES ATTACK THE PRESENCE OF
COVER. NINETEEN NOT TO TREAT
COVER NINETEEN. A SEPARATE THE
LEVEL LINE IMPORTANT PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURES AND ENSURE THAT
OPTOMETRISTS CAN CONTINUE TO
SERVE THEIR PATIENTS AND
OPERATE SAFELY. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU THIS MORNING AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES. FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME NAME
AFFILIATION ONLY IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO. THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION OF THE
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
WHERE THEY- OPERATED WE'RE IN
THE- OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF
POST BEGIN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
IT'S IS A SUPPORT. I'M SORRY
BUT- THANK. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO. AGAIN THIS IS MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY ONE. NO LINE TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR.
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS OPERATE WOULD
YOU PLEASE UP THE LINE FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME TO ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU TO YOUR
PROJECT IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE. AND THERE ARE NO
LINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
ORINDA COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. EMAIL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAD YOU WISH
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE JUST- WE ARE MISSING
ONE AND- LET'S SEE. IF WE COULD
JUST PAUSE THERE FOR A MOMENT
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. HELLO
HERE FLORA ARAMBULA BERMAN.
BLOOM CHEN CHIU CUNNINGHAM
DALLY FONG GIPSON GRAYSON
HOLDEN. IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA.
MULLIN SALAS KING. WITH THE
STOPS THE COR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE STATUS CORN THIS BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND. ON AB SIX
NINETY ONE COMMITTEE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY
SIX NINETY ONE CHILD TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW- HI
FLORA FLORA HI ARAMBULA. BERMAN
BERMAN HI BLOOM. BLOOM HI CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DELLY
DELLY HI FONG FONG HI GIPSON
GIPSON GRAYSONGRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN. IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA IN
A AYE MULLIN. SALAS KING. TEN
FIVE ZERO KNOWS. CAN I USE THAT
BILL IS OUT WITH THE- ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. HI WILL
MOVE TO CONSENT CALENDAR IN THE
MEDIA HAVE TO OPPORTUNITY TO RE
READ IT OUT A TODAY WE WILL
HAVE ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOME AMERICORPS WELL
OF ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY TWO
BY SIMILAR CARILLO ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR SEVENTY ONE BY SUMMER
LOW. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE ZERO
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FIFTEEN BY SOMEONE MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO AND ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY TWO BY FAMILY
MEMBER CHAD. THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION IS THERE A SECOND THE
SECOND BY VICE CHAIR FLOOR
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB TWO EIGHT SEVEN QUIRK A
BEAST FOUR SIX TWO CORREO AB
FOUR SEVEN ONE LOW AB FIVE ZERO
ONE CRISTINA GARCIA AB TEN
FIFTEEN BLANCA RUBIO AB. TWELVE
TWENTY TWO CHEN DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA ALRIGHT
ARAMBULA. BERMAN BERMAN I
BLOOM. BLOOM HI CHEN. CHEN AYE
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DELLY DELLY HI
FONG. FONG ALL RIGHT GIPSON
GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN. IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN SALAS CHANGE.
TEN I. ZERO NOTICE TONIGHT ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES WILL BEEN
MOVE INTO FILE ORDER AND SEEING
THE ABSENCE OF ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS AND FOLLOW ORDER WILL
THEN GO OVER TO MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE. THEN THAT BEGINS IN
FALL ORDER OF WITH A FILE ORDER
NUMBER TEN. THIS IS. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN THIRTY FOUR YOU
SHOULD. THE AUTHOR BE AVAILABLE
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL TEN.
THIRTY FOUR FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN. WHERE. COLLEAGUES THIS
AGAIN FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. I'M
SORRY MISTER CHAIR I HAD TO.
FILE ITEM TEN IS- DOCTOR WITH
THE BILL THAT'S WHY I WAS
STARING BLANKLY- SO THIS IS- AB
AT A TEN THIRTY FOUR- PERHAPS
APPROPRIATE THAT IT'S- A FOUR
TWENTY TODAY. I THINK IT'S NOT
THE ONLY CANNABIS BILL THAT WE
HAVE TO OF. HOPEFULLY I'LL GET
TO WORK- THIS BILL PASSES WILL
BE CAUSE FOR CELEBRATION IN
ADDITION TO THAT WHICH MIGHT
ALREADY BE OCCURRING THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY HEY P. TEN THIRTY
FOUR CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
THAT ALREADY- ALLOWS LOCAL
JURISDICTION PERMIT CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES. IF THEY
WISH. I RESPECTFULLY DECLINE
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AT
THIS TIME BUT I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE ISSUE IN
A CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS IT. I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE- AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK. ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CAN PERMIT
CANNABIS CONSUMPTION LOUNGES
BUT THERE IS NO COMPARABLE
CONSUMPTION LOUNGE LICENSE AT
THE STATE LEVEL. SO LOCAL
LOUNGES MUST RECEIVE A STATE
RETAIL LICENSE. THIS BECOMES
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE STATE RULES
FOR CANNABIS RETAIL LICENSE
DON'T FULLY ALIGNED WITH THE
BUSINESS PRACTICES OF CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES.
SPECIFICALLY CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES OPERATE
THAT HOSPITALITY BUSINESSES
SIMILAR TO BARS AND
RESTAURANTS. NOT RETAIL OUTLETS.
THE MOST CRITICAL DIFFERENCE IS
THAT MOST CANNABIS CONSUMPTION
LOANS BUSINESS MODELS INCLUDE
THE SALE OF NON CANNABIS FOOD
AND BEVERAGES. NON ALCOHOLIC
SIMILAR TO HOW BARS AND
RESTAURANTS OPERATE. STATE LAW
DOES NOT ALLOW CANNABIS
BUSINESSES TO SELL ANY ITEMS
OTHER THAN CANNABIS AND
CANNABIS PRODUCTS THUS CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES ARE UNABLE
TO SELL NON CANNABIS FOOD AND
BEVERAGES- AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NON ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
HERE. AB TEN THIRTY FOUR WOULD
ALLOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
PERMIT THE SALE AND PREPARATION
OF NON CANNABIS FOOD AND NON
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES IN CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES. THIS WOULD
BE A COMPLETELY LOCAL DECISION
NO CITY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PERMIT IT. THE FOOD AND
BEVERAGES PREPARED AND SOLD ON
SITE WOULD NOT BE INFUSED WITH
CANNABIS AND THE BEVERAGES
WOULD BE AS I MENTIONED NON
ALCOHOLIC. THIS BILL SIMPLY
ALLOWS A LOCAL JURISDICTION TO
ALLOW CANNABIS CONSUMPTION
LOUNGES TO ALSO PREPARE AND
SELL NON CANNABIS FOOD AND
BEVERAGES. THAT ARE NON
ALCOHOLIC TO THEIR CUSTOMERS IF
THEY WISH AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TEN
THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. IN A
STAND THAT WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN MINOR
NINE THE COMMUNITY AND
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR
THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD. I
ALSO LEAD THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE CITY'S CANNABIS WORKING. AS
MENTIONED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AB TEN THIRTY FOUR WILL
ALLOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THE
ABILITY TO PERMIT THE SALE AND
PREPARATION OF NON CANNABIS
FOOD AND BEVERAGES YOU CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES. THE SALE
IN PREPARATION OF NON CANNABIS
FOOD AND BEVERAGES IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CONSUMPTION
LOUNGES BECAUSE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BLEW MENTIONED THEY OPERATE AS
HOSPITALITY BUSINESSES. AS
OPPOSED TO RETAIL STORES. IN
THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD WE
WILL BE PERMITTED UP TO SIXTEEN
CANNABIS CONSUMPTION. WITHOUT
THE CHANGES IN AB TEN THIRTY
FOUR CONSUMPTION LOUNGES
INCLUDING THOSE IN WEST
HOLLYWOOD WILL BE UNABLE TO
SELL ANY NON CANNABIS. BEVERAGE
PROJECTS THE PRODUCT. LIBERTY
AND OTHER NEARBY BUSINESSES.
SIMILAR TO HOW WE WOULD HAVE
FOOD DELIVERED TO OUR HOUSE.
THIS IS AN INEFFICIENT BUSINESS
MODEL AND DOES NOT ALLOW
CANNABIS CONSUMPTION BY JUST
TWO PEOPLE SERVICE HOSPITALITY
BUSINESSES. AS CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION INCREASE A TYPE OF
BUSINESS IN THE STATE NOW IS
THE TIME TO CLARIFY THE LAW. SO
THE BUSINESSES AS THEY COMPLETE
THEIR TENANT IMPROVEMENTS IN
BUILT APPS WILL KNOW WHAT THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO PREPARE AND
SELL APPLICATION INCLUDING ON
CAMPUS FOOD AND BEVERAGES.
LASTLY I WOULD ADD THE ONLY
DURING THE AT ONE CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES BE IN BY
BUDGET. TO MEET THE DON'T ONE
CONCERT LOUNGES NOT BE IN. IN
CAN IN AND CAN TO SUCH ISSUES.
WE FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
SIMPLE CHANGE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MUCH OUR THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC WITH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT THIS TIME NAME. OF
WISH TO DO. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND. ZERO MY NUMBER FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. RESEARCHER
MEMBERS GRAND MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CMG KHALIF IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE NUMBER SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS EDDIE FRANCO ON HAPPY
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. I THANK
YOU JUST ONE MORE MOMENT FOR
NEXT PERSON. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIR ON JUNE
BEHALF OF AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS AND SUPPORT. THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR C.
NOTITIA MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT WHEN I MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION HE'S GOING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
CHAMBERS OR THE COMMITTEE ROOMS
AT THIS TIME WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM TO
WISH TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THE LAW IN A WAY THAT SUPPORTS
LOCAL BUSINESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DERIVE A-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR BLOOM
HAS YOU KNOW TO I HAVE. HAD THE
PLEASURE OF VISITING YOU IN
DISTRICT AND ALSO SEEING MUCH
OF THIS- IN THE AREA OF
JURISDICTION AND- AND- HOPEFUL
THAT WE STAY DEEPLY COMMITTED
TO THE BASIC PROTECTIONS. OUT
ON. ALLOWING THE- INDUSTRY TO
THRIVE ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE PUBLIC SAFETY AS A HIGH
REGARD- AND- WITH RESPECT TO
THE COMMITTEE MEN'S- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'LL BE
ADDRESSING THEM MOVING FORWARD
SO- WILL. BE DUE HAVING TO DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
BILL AS IT IS WITHOUT ANY AMEND.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND IS A
SET. SO I'M MISTER MEDINA
TWENTY SIX APRIL CALL THE ROLL.
MAYBE TEN THIRTY FOUR BLOOM TO
PASS HELLO I LOW HIGH FLORIDA
FLORA I RAN. BERMAN BERMAN I
BLEW HI BLAME AYE CHAN. CHIU
CUNNINGHAM. DALY FONG. GIPSON
GIPSON GRAYSON. HOLDEN IRWIN.
MCCARTY MEDINA. MEDINA HI
MULLIN. SALAS KING. SIX FIVE
ZERO KNOWS. THIS BILL WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU IT BUT WITH- MISTER
MURPHY COULD HAVE A PAUSE WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL AUTHORS HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS THAT ARE NOT
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE SO
CALLS WILL GO BACK INTO FILE
ORDER- ON ON MY SHOULD HAVE A
FILE ITEM OR FOR IS A BILL TWO
SIXTY NINE. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON THIS DOES ENJOY TO
PASS ON BOTH OF THE AISLE.
THANK YOU FOR IT A WILL WITH
THIS MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- CAL.
NUR CHORE IS NOT NEW. BUT
DURING THE PAST YEAR. THEM WE
WILL DO SEE HOW CRITICAL IT'S-
A TWO SIX NINE WILL ALLOW. NOW
TO RENEW THEIR LICENSE FOR
REDUCED FEE. WILL STILL BE
ONGOING EDUCATION REQUIRE SO
THAT THEY OFFER THEIR SERVICES
INVOLVED COULD. EITHER ON A
REGULAR. ON A- THE CITY. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA READY
OFFERS THIS BENEFIT OTHER
HEALTH FOR. THE MEDICAL BOARD
ALLOWS RETIRED DOCTORS TO
REDUCE LICENSES AT REDUCED RATE
IN THE DENTAL BOARD. UP THE
SAME- TO UNDERSTAND UNDERSCORE
THE VALUE OF THE REDUCE LICENSE
RENEWAL FEE FOR RETIRED NURSES
WE HAVE TO TESTIFIED SUPPORT
CHOICE. EATEN OF THE NURSING
LEADERSHIP COALITION OF THE
SALMON VALLEY. END OF MEMBER
CHAIRED AS WILL BE GREAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OF OPERATOR YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
MISSY. THIS IF YOU'RE CALL
LIMIT YOUR- TO KNOW MORE TWO.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. YOU
MISTER. I ENJOY EATEN RAW. THE
NURSING LEADERSHIP. OF THE-
PANEL CAN VARY. RECOVERED NINE
TEN MAKES CRY. YOU MORE EVER
HOUSE WE ARE IN THE DOWN. BUT
THEN. WORK FOR IN THIS IS OUR-
BY OUR WORK FORCE DATACOM IN
FROM. AND WE- MUCH NEED TO KNOW
THAT GO TO ARE. RETIRED WOULD
BE WILLING. TO RENEW THEIR- SO
THAT THEY CAN BE AVAILABLE. AND
I CAN. IT MAY OF OUR NURSES IN
THE- CAP. UP DURING THIS TIME
TO WORK IN OUR KOBE. SUPPORTED
BY THE COUNT. AND WE ARE NOW
THAT- WE ARE HERE SERVE. NOT
ONLY DIFFERENT OF ALLEY OTHER.
THAT CAL. AS WELL. SO EVEN
THOUGH I. THE CENTRAL. I'LL
SERVE ON THE OFFENSE. ACCOUNT
NURSE. THE AMERICAN NURSING A-
CAL. AND IF IT'S A WHITE. ME IN
THE STATE OF. SO ON THE THERE'S
ANY. I CAN'T. NINE HAPPY DO
THAT OTHER. I LOOK FORWARD IT I.
ON THIS ISSUE. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR SAY NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS
OR IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION.
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ON THE LINES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MEASURE
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
YOUR. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
THE CHAMBERS OR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. DURING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
C. NINE A SEVEN PATTERSON DO
WISH TO CLOSE. A VERY BRIEFLY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- I VOTE ON
AB TWO SIX NINE AND MISTER
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU
FOR THE A SYSTEM MOVING THE
BILL. YEAH VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND THEN- MR PATTERSON
SHOULD KNOW THAT. THIS
COMMITTEE TYPICALLY HAS NOT
SUPPORTED. SUCH BILLS OUTSIDE
OF THE PROCESS OF THE SUNSET
HEARINGS BUT- MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE. I HAD THIS
COMMITMENT A CONVERSATION WITH
YOU TO HELP. ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
MOVING FORWARD AS WE UNDERSTAND
IS ALSO DISTRICT ISSUE. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO YOU. AND THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWO SIX NINE PATTERSON TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH
LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA ARAMBULA.
BERMAN BERMAN HI BLOOM BLOOM HI
CHAN CHEN AYE CHIU. CUNNINGHAM
DALLI DALLI HI FONG FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON HI HOLDEN. IRWIN IRWIN
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN. SALAS CHANGE.
TWELVE FIVE ZERO KNOWS TWELVE
EYES WILL LEAVE THE OLD WILL
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE ALSO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY
TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
THIS ALSO DOES ENJOY JACKASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. BRIGITTE UP FOUR
NINE TO THE BILL WILL HELP
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
STUDENTS SIMULTANEOUSLY PAPER
SOME OF THEIR EDUCATION COSTS
WHILE GIVING THEM VALUABLE
HANDS ON EXPERIENCE. THE BOARD
OF- BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
OFFER STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR CLASSROOM
EDUCATION WITH HANDS ON
EXPERIENCE. THROUGH THE
EXTERNSHIP PROGRAM OF A FEW
STUDENTS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE OF CURRENT
LIMITATIONS- SPECIFICALLY
EXPERIENCE CANNOT BE PAID
ANYTHING FOR THEIR SERVICES AND
CLOCK HOURS THAT CAN BE EARNED
IS CAPPED AT. 10% EIGHTY FOUR
NINE TWO WILL UPDATE THE
EXTERNSHIP PROGRAM TO REFLECT
THE NEEDS AND ABILITIES. OF THE
STUDENTS- THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE IN
EXTERNSHIPS AFTER COMPLETING
25% OF THEIR COURSE WORK. AS
OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT SIXTY
PERCENT- TO COMPLETE 25% OF
THEIR CLOCK OUR CREDITS- IN A
PROFESSIONAL SETTING. ALSO
ALLOWS STUDENTS TO PAY FOR
SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE WELL
IN A- PROFESSIONAL SETTING-
BRIEFLY TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILLS SPREAD JONES. HE
REPRESENTS THE PROFESSIONAL
BEAUTY FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND KYLE RUMBLE
WITH SALON SUCCESS ACADEMICS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES OF
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE TWO
INDIVIDUALS IF YOU COULD KINDLY
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT MANY READY HOME
AGAIN WITH MISTER FRED JONES.
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER JONES ARE YOU
THERE. HEARING THE AND NOTHING
FROM MR JOHNSON OF WITH THE
SECOND PRIMARY WHEN YOU SWITCH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. PLEASE CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW THIS IS BRETT
JONES YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SORRY ABOUT THAT NOT QUITE SURE
WHAT HAPPENED TREJOS ON BEHALF
OF THE PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA IN LIGHT
OF THE I DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
ON BOTH SIDES. REACHED WE THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ALL THREE THIS
BILL THERE ARE TWO PRIMARY
MEANS BY WHICH ARE SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS LICENSED.
BUYER C. BOARD TO GET A
LICENSE. ONE IS THROUGH AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND THE
OTHER IS TO FORMAL EDUCATION.
THERE'S STILL WITH THE FORMER.
ROUTE THE BASSINET OF OUR SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL
LICENSEES. AND IT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO GO TO WORK IN A SALON
SETTING WITH THE OPTION OF
BEING PAID BY THE SALON OWNER.
WHILE THEY ARE EARNING THEIR
CLOCK OUR CREDIT SO THIS IS A
MEANS OF ADDRESSING BARRIERS TO
ENTRY INTO OUR INDUSTRY AND
GIVING THEM REAL WORLD
EXPERIENCE BEFORE THEY PUT
THEIR LIVES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER JOHNS NOW
TO THE SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. THE MORNING GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KYLE RUMBLE AND I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF FINANCE AND
PERSONNEL PERSONAL ON SUCCESS
ACADEMY A POST SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION WAS SIX
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TRAINING STUDENTS IN THE FIELD
OF COSMETOLOGY BARBERING
ESTHETICS MANICURE AND SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY. I ALSO
REPRESENT OUR OWNER ROBERT
GROSS WHO THE PRIMARY SPONSOR
TO THE ORIGINAL EXTERNSHIP BILL.
WE HAVE AN INSTITUTION AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ROBERT
ARE ALL ABOUT STUDENT
OPPORTUNITY AND STUDENT
SUCCESS. AND BELIEVE EXPANDING
THE EXTERNSHIP PROGRAM ACCOUNT
ACCOMPLISHES BOTH. ALL OF OUR
SCHOOLS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
CURRENT PROGRAM WHICH CAN
PROVIDE STUDENTS ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY TO GET REAL WORLD
SALON EXPERIENCE THAT COULD BE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE CAN
PROVIDE. IT CAN HELP STUDENTS
BUILD A NETWORK OF SALON OWNERS
HERE'S AND CLIENTELE EVEN
BEFORE GRADUATING. LOOKING BACK
AT OUR CAREERS WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT NETWORKING IS TO
FUTURE SUCCESSES AS
PROFESSIONAL. IT CAN HELP
STUDENTS PREPARE FOR SOMEONE
LIKE AFTER LIKE GINGER KNOWING
WHAT MAY BE EXPECTED OF THEM
AFTER PASSING IMPORTS. IT CAN
ALSO HELP STUDENTS LAND THAT
COVETED FIRST JOB AFTER LIKE
IN. THE BEST CASE SCENARIO
WOULD BE KEEPING A POSITION
EVEN BEFORE GRADUATING FROM
SCHOOL. AND HAVING A JOB
WAITING FOR THEM ONE SELECTION.
EXPANDING THE EXTERNSHIP
PROGRAM IS ONLY GOING TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES NOW FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SIGNIFY THEIR AYE SUPPORT.
AGAIN OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MEASURE TO TAKE
THE KIDS FOR PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SHOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AND THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SCHEME NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
OR THE COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE- EFFORT THE
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S BEEN OUT
OF. A GOOD LEARNING EXPERIENCE
FOR ME AND- I APPRECIATED VERY
MUCH AS WE WORK THROUGH THAT
THE BILL THANK YOU FOR THE-
IBM. SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION-
ASK FOR YOUR YE VOTE AND
APPRECIATE HER MUCH THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON COULD DISAGREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB FOUR NINE TWO
PATTERSON TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA FLORA ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA BAKER BERMAN. BERMAN
HI BLOOM BLOOM HI CHAN CHAN HI
Q. CUNNINGHAM DALLI DELLY HI
FONG. FONG HI GIPSON- GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON HI HOLDEN.
IRWIN IRWIN HI MCCARTY MCCARTY
MEDINA MEDINA HI MULLIN. SALAS
CHANGE. THIRTY NINE ZERO KNOWS
I. BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JIM PATTERSON
COLLEAGUES WILL MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH SUMMERS
WITH THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE PLEASE FEEL FREE
PRESENT WHENEVER READY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. AB
TEN TWENTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE
EVERY BOARD WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
TO GRANT A 50% FEE REDUCTION
INITIALIZES. TO AN APPLICANT
WHO SERVED ON ACTIVE DUTY
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD. OR THE UNITED
STATES ARMED FORCES AND WAS
HONORABLY DISCHARGED. VETERANS
FACE NUMEROUS CHALLENGES WHEN
TRANSITIONING FROM ACTIVE DUTY
TO THE CIVILIAN WORKFORCE.
INITIAL LICENSE FEES FOR BOARDS
WITHIN IT DCA. CAN PROVE
BURDENSOME EXPRESSLY FOR LOWER
INCOME VETERANS. REDUCING THESE
FEES BY 50% WOULD HELP REMOVE
THE FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO ENTER
LICENSED PROFESSIONS VETERANS
OFFER OFTEN GAIN VALUABLE JOB
SKILLS DURING MILITARY SERVICE
WHICH CAN BE USED UPON ENTERING
THE CIVILIAN WORKFORCE. EASING
THIS FINANCIAL BURKE AND BRING
SKILLED LABOR TO THE CALIFORNIA
AND HELP CHIP AWAY IN THE
GROWING ISSUE OF VETERANS
HOMELESSNESS. IN OUR STATE.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
AMERICAN LEGION. AMVETS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDER
VETERANS COUNCIL. AND THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB. TEN TWENTY SIX. AND
I HAVE A WITNESS MR DANA
NICHOLS ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN LEGION AMVETS AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK OU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE HELP WITH OF
THE LINE FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DANA AND NICOLE
WITH READ GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS. CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDER VETERANS
COUNCIL. AM BEST. IN THE
AMERICAN LEGION IN SUPPORT. AS
A SETTLEMENT SMITH STATED THIS
WILL HELP VETERANS RE ENTER OR
ENTER THE WORKFORCE FOR THE
FIRST TIME MANY OF THESE YOUNG
VETERANS PUT THEIR LIVES ON
HOLD TO SERVE OUR COUNTRY AND
AFTER THEIR TWO FOR SIX. YEARS
OR CAN'T EVEN TEN YEARS OF
SERVICE THEY ARE COMING BACK
INTO A WORK FORCE OF THE THEY
NEED TO THEY NEED SOME HELP
GETTING BACK INTO- SOUL. BUT
NEVER I NEVER USE YOU'LL WANT
TO COVER IS THAT THE PROCESS
FOR BEING- CERTIFIED AS A
VETERAN IS TO GO TO THE- IS TO
USE THE VETERAN DRIVER'S
LICENSE WHICH IS AUTHORIZED BY
THE COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICERS THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
CLEAR. A PERSON TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE A VETERAN. IN THIS
PROCESS WHAT IT DOES IT HELPS-
IT HELPS PBSO ALSO PRE SCREEN
THESE VETERANS FOR ANY POSSIBLE
FEDERAL BUT VA. BENEFITS THEY
MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR. EACH YEAR
SO DOES BRING IN A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR. IN CALIFORNIA
VETERANS BENEFITS WHICH ARE
PAID FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DIRECTLY TO THE
VETERAN. AND THIS MONEY IS
SPENT IN THE LOCAL ECONOMIES
AND THAT BRINGS REVENUE TO
STATE AND LOCAL ECONOMIES SO.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
GET OUR VETERANS. TO WORK IN
MEANINGFUL OCCUPATIONS IT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT WE GET OUR
VETERANS THE BENEFITS THEY
DESERVE WHICH ARE VERY
COMPLICATED TO APPLY FOR. A
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICERS ARE THE ONES THAT DO
THAT AND IT REALLY BEHOOVES THE
STATE. TO THE TUNE OF ALMOST A
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR-
COMING IN- TO BE SET TO
VETERANS TO SPEND A LOCAL
ECONOMIES. IT ALSO ANY VETERANS
FROM THE VA. OF BENEFITS
PROGRAMS ALSO IT REMOVES THAT
BEDROOM FROM ALREADY IMPACTED
ST LOS MOBILE PROGRAM SO ALL
THIS TIME TOGETHER IT COULD BE
A HUGE. BENEFIT TO THE STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I A ANY MEMBER OF THE WHICH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU TO SHARE TO TRY TO
SPEAK N. SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE NINETY. THERE ARE NO LINES
TO SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR
THE COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHICH IS SPEAKING
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MEASURE THANK BEACON
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENIOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS
OR IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH WAS
THE CLOSEST. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AB TEN
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EMBARRASSMENT THAT YOU KNOW
THEY CHAIR THE VETERANS
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE SIMPLY
ALSO SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE
HAS GIVEN GIVEN HIGH REMARKS
FOR THIS BILL AS WELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING IN FORT
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TEN TWENTY SIX
MATH DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW- HI
FLORA. FLORA ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
BAKER BERMAN HI BERMAN I BLOOM.
BLOOM I CAN. CHAIN IQ.
CUNNINGHAM DELLY DELLY ALL
RIGHT FONG FONG ALL RIGHT
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
RECENT HI HOLDEN IRWIN IRWIN HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN SALAS TEAM.
THIRTY NINE ZERO KNOWS THIRTEEN
EYES WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF SUMMER SMITH
CALLING SEE NO ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS NOT ON THIS COMMITTEE
WILL GO THEN TO. AUTHORS
PRESENTING THAT ARE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND SO WILL THEN
GO BACK IT TOO- MISTER BLOOM
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE.
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU AGAIN AND
A GOOD MORNING AGAIN THIS CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'D
FIRST LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR TIRELESS CONTINUE EFFORT
WORKING. ON US WITH THE- ON
THIS BILL AB TWELVE EIGHTY TO
THE CALIFORNIA PET BLOOD BANK
MODERNIZATION ACT SEEKS TO
PHASE OUT THE OBSOLETE AND
INHUMANE PRACTICE OF CAPTIVE
CLOSED COLONY CANINE BLOOD
BANKS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BY AUTHORIZING
CALIFORNIA LICENSED
VETERINARIANS TO OPERATE
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS TO
PRODUCE AND SELL OR TRANSPORT
TRANSFER ANIMAL BLOOD AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS. VETERINARY
TECHNICIANS AND VETERINARY
ASSISTANCE MAY ALSO COLLECT THE
BLOOD FROM AN ANIMAL UNDER
DIRECT OR INDIRECT SUPERVISION
OF A LICENSED VETERINARIAN. THE
BILL PLACES THE PRACTICE OF
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKING UNDER
THE JURISDICTION AND OVERSIGHT
OF THE VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD.
EXCUSE ME AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
MODERNIZES CALIFORNIA LAW BY
PROVIDING A SAFE ETHICALLY
SOURCED ANIMAL BLOOD SUPPLY FOR
USE IN VETERINARY PRACTICE. THE
BILL AUTHORIZES COMMUNITY BLOOD
BANKS WHICH ARE SIMILAR TO
HUMAN BLOOD BANKS IN THE SENSE
THAT ALLOWS BLOOD COLLECTION
FROM PETS WHOSE OWNERS HAVE
VOLUNTARILY CONSENTED TO THE
DONATION. CURRENTLY THIS
VOLUNTARY COMMUNITY BLOOD
COMMUNITY BASED APPROACH ISN'T
ALLOWED IN CALIFORNIA AT ALL.
INSTEAD CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY THAT
REQUIRES ANIMAL BLOOD TO COME
FROM SO CALLED CLOSED COLONY
BLOOD BANKS. IN CLOSE CALL IN
THE BLOOD BANKS BLOOD IS SOURCE
FROM DOGS THAT ARE CAPPED
HOUSED OR MAINTAINED AT A
FACILITY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
COLLECTING THEIR BLOOD. THESE
CLOTHES COLONY BLOOD BANKS
REQUIRE HUNDREDS OF DOGS TO BE
IN CAGES FOR YEARS WHILE THEIR
BLOOD IS ROUTINELY HARVESTED.
I'M PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT CLOSE COLONY CONDITIONS
THAT KEEP CANINES CAGED IN
TIGHT SPACES DEPRIVED OF
EXERCISE AND MENTAL STIMULATION.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO ALLOWS FOR
A MORE HUMANE SOLUTION FOR
SOURCING ANIMAL BLOOD WHILE
ALSO ESTABLISHING CONDITIONS TO
EVENTUALLY PHASE OUT CAPTIVE
CLOSE QUALITY CANINE BLOOD
BANKS. AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO WAS
RECENTLY AMENDED TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE RAISED IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS OVER THE PAST
YEARS. THE BILL NOW ENSURES
THAT COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS
FOLLOW THE BEST MOST RECENT
CLINICAL PRACTICES AND
STANDARDS FOR VETERINARY
TRANSFUSION MEDICINE AND
DIRECTS THE VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD TO UPON APPROPRIATION
FROM THE LEGISLATURE HIRE A
CONSULTANT TO ASSIST IN
DEVELOPING GUIDELINES AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR VETERINARIANS TO
FOLLOW WHEN THEY'RE OPERATING
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS. THOSE
MOST AFFECTED BY THIS
LEGISLATION OR THE
VETERINARIANS WHO MUST HAVE
RELIABLE SOURCES OF BLOOD AND
BLOOD COMPONENTS TO SAVE THE
LIVES OF THE DOGS AND CATS IN
THEIR HOSPITALS. ONE OF THE
MAJOR CONCERNS OF THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IS ENSURING THAT
BLOOD AND BLOOD PRODUCTS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE ONCE
THOSE LAWS IMPLEMENTED. AND
THAT THE QUALITY OF THESE
PRODUCTS IS MAINTAINED. MY
STAFF AND I ARE CONTINUED ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE C. VMA AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF FINDING THE
APPROPRIATE TRIGGER FOR THE
PHASE OUT OF THE CLOSE CALL IN
THE MODEL. THE APRIL FIFTEENTH
AMENDED VERSION OF THE BILL
DIRECTLY ADDRESSES THIS CONCERN
AS THERE IS LANGUAGE IN PLACE
THAT REQUIRES BLOOD PRODUCTS TO
BE EQUAL TO OR EXCEED THE
AVERAGE AMOUNT. THAT CLOSED
COLONY BLOOD BANK SOLD IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY BEFORE FULLY
DISCONTINUING CLOSE COLONY
CANINE BLOOD BANKS. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO WOULD EVENTUALLY
PHASE OUT AND ELIMINATE THE USE
OF CAPTIVE CLOSE COLONY CANINE
BLOOD BANKS IN CALIFORNIA. ONCE
IT IS DETERMINED THAT COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANKS ARE PRODUCING EQUAL
TO OR EXCEEDING THE SUPPLY OF
BLOOD PRODUCED CURRENTLY BY
CAPTIVE BLOOD BANKS. MEMBERS
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT SENATOR
WILK AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
PASSIONATELY FOR THREE YEARS
AND IT IS OUR HOPE THAT THIS
WILL BE THE YEAR VETERINARIANS
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THE AFFECTED
STATE DEPARTMENTS. CAN ALL
AGREE THAT IT ETHICALLY SOURCED
SAFE AND EXPANDED ANIMAL BLOOD
SUPPLY FOR VETERINARY USE IS
NECESSARY AND POSSIBLE. CALLING
IN TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL OR DOCTOR CAN PULASKI
THE CLINICAL DIRECTOR AT
INSIGHT VETERINARY WELLNESS
CENTER. AND DR JEANINE BERGER
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF RESCUE
AND WELFARE AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOOM OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR OUR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES EACH PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
READY. MY NAME IS KATIE O.
SHIZUKA I AM PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS. AND D. AS
IT CAN BE INFERRED MINISTRATION
THE TORY UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE OF PHARMACY. I AM
LICENSED TO PRACTICE LAW AND
PHARMACY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS AND HOSPITALS HAVE
BEEN ORDERING AND INTERPRETING
LABORATORY TESTS SINCE THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES. MISTER
CHAIRMAN HOLDEN CLINICS OF THE
ROBBERY OF A PART. OF TWO COULD
YOU JUST CHECK I KILEY POSSUM I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE THE ON THE
WRONG BILL THIS IS IT FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL- A TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO. NO. THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT.
THE WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE YET
THAT IS- FILE ITEM OF FOURTEEN
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INTEREST WE'RE CURRENTLY ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. OKAY
TO GIVE YOU HAS GOT KILEY PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT I WILL BE THERE
SHORTLY AND SO AGAIN WE'LL GO
BACK TO OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY TWO. OKAY
THE- OTHERS CAN PULL OUT YOU
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I AM TESTIFYING TODAY
TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO TO HELP
INCREASE IN ASSURING THE
ADEQUATE STATE SUPPLY CHAIN I
BLOOD PREVENTING OR ANYTHING
CALIFORNIA. FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO SINCERELY THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM FIRST
PERSON PARENTS AND PERSISTENCE
ON THIS ISSUE. I KNOW IT HAS
BEEN CHALLENGING. MY NAME IS DR
KEN PULASKI AND I AM A
VETERINARIAN LICENSE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CLINICAL
DIRECTOR AND OWNER OF INSECT
VETERINARY WELLNESS CENTER. A
SMALL ANIMAL HOSPITAL IN
ELDORADO HILLS PROVIDING
PRIMARY CARE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
EMERGENCY CARE. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE EIGHT VETERINARIANS
INCLUDING A FULL TIME BOARDED
CRITICAL US PLUS A PART TIME
INTERNIST AND CONTRACTED
CARDIOLOGISTS AND SURGEONS.
PRIOR TO OPENING OUR HOSPITAL
LAST YEAR WE OWN TO BANFIELD
HOSPITALS DAYTIME GENERAL
PRACTICES. IN THOSE HOSPITALS
ARE NEED FOR BLOOD IS FAIRLY
RARE AND IF WE DID NEED IT WE
CAN USUALLY COLLECTED FROM ONE
OF OUR STAFF PAT BURKE IT WAS
MORE CRITICAL WE REFERRED TO AN
EMERGENCY HOSPITAL. NOW IS AN
EMERGENCY HOSPITAL IS A WHOLE
NEW BALLGAME. WE NEVER KNOW
WHEN WE WILL NEED BLOOD OR
BLOOD PRODUCTS. BUT THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN WE HAVE MULTIPLE
PETS IN NEED. OFTEN REQUIRING
MULTIPLE UNITS. WE HAD ONE
MASTER'S-LEVEL SERGIO SURGERY
RECENTLY ENDED UP NEEDING FOUR
UNITS OF WHOLE BLOOD OR PACKED
RED BLOOD CELLS AND FOUR UNITS
OF PLASMA. AFTER USING OUR IN
HOUSE LAST NIGHT ANY UNIT OF
BLOOD COLLECTED FROM THE
TECHNICIANS DOGS WE HAD TO
BORROW BLOOD AND PLASMA FROM
THREE OTHER EMERGENCY HOSPITALS
INCLUDING ONE ALL THE WAY OUT
AND FAIRFIELD. EFFECTIVELY
WIPING OUT THE BLOOD SUPPLY IN
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA.
THIS FORCES US TO MAKE HARD
CHOICES BETWEEN WHICH PATIENTS
WILL RECEIVE BLOOD PRODUCTS.
THERE SIMPLY IS NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH BLOOD TO THE PATIENTS
WHO NEED IT. WELL I UNDERSTAND
AND APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS FOR
THE DOGS THAT ARE CONFINED TO
THE TO CLOSE COLONY BLOOD
BANKS. MY BIGGER CONCERN IS
RELATED TO THE INADEQUATE
SUPPLY OF BLOOD AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS FOR PATIENTS. THESE
TWO COMPANIES SIMPLY CANNOT
SUPPLY THE NEEDS OF CRITICALLY
ILL AND INJURED PACKING
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS WHY I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
WHICH WILL ALLOW VETERINARIANS
TO ESTABLISH COMMUNITY BASED
BLOOD BANKS TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE BLOOD AVAILABLE TO
OUR PATIENTS. IN ADDITION IT
WILL ALLOW US TO IMPORT THESE
PRODUCTS FROM OUT OF STATE AS
LONG AS THEY MEET OUR SAFETY
STANDARDS. WE ALSO NEED TO BE
ASSURED THAT BLOOD AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS COMING FROM ALL
SOURCES REMAIN SAFE. SO IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT STANDARDS AND
GUIDELINES BE ESTABLISHED TO
ASSURE NOT ONLY AN ADEQUATE
SUPPLY BUT ALSO SIX O'CLOCK. I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO MAKE A ONE
TIME APPROPRIATION TO ALLOW FOR
SETTING UP THESE GUIDELINES. I
TRULY HOPE NONE OF YOUR PETS
EVER NEEDS A TRANSFUSION. BUT
IF THEY WOULD WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO NOTE THAT THERE WAS BLOOD
AVAILABLE FOR THEM. PLEASE VOTE
HI AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR NOW
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND PRIMARY
WIN THIS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR JEANINE
BERGER AND I'M LICENSED
CALIFORNIA VETERINARIAN AND THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT. OF
FRANCE YOU AND I'M A WELFARE
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO AT FIFTY
EIGHT. THREE UC DAVIS I AM
BOARD CERTIFIED WITH BOTH THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF VETERINARY
BEHAVIORIST. ANTI AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF ANIMAL WELFARE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN I
HAVE OVERSEEING ALL ASPECTS OF
CLINICAL BEHAVIOR AND WELFARE
PROGRAMS AT THE SAN FRANCISCO
SPCA. I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE
YOU TO WORK I. AB TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO TO MODERNIZE CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL BLOOD BANKING INDUSTRY.
VETERINARIANS AND THE PUBLIC
ARE INCREASINGLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WELFARE STATUS OF
ANIMALS IN SOCIETY. THESE
CHANGES HAVE IMPACTED MOST
AREAS OF THAT NATURE PRACTICE
INCLUDING THE CANINE BLOOD
BANKING INDUSTRY. THE CURRENT
SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA IS
EGREGIOUSLY ON BALANCE. BLOOD
DONOR STOCKS ARE KEPT CONFINED
FOR MONTHS. OR YEARS IN
APPALLING CONDITIONS. FOR IN A
MOVE THAT RECOGNIZE BEING NEEDS
OF DAHLE. MANY BLOOD BANKS THE
HAVE TRUMP FROM CLOSE COLONY.
THE COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS
THAT COLLECT BLOOD FROM
PRESCREEN HEALTHY FAMILY PETS.
YEAH SIX DAYS OUR SUCCESSFUL
PROTOCOLS AND ESTABLISH
PROTOCOLS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE. CALIFORNIA VETERINARIANS
POSSESS THE NECESSARY EDUCATION
AND SKILLS TO MODERNIZE THIS
INDUSTRY IN IN WAYS THAT ARE
PRACTICAL SAFE AND HUMANE WE
ARE EAGER TO WORK TOGETHER AS A
PROFESSION TO MAKE COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANKS THE STANDARD OF
CARE. THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA
ASKED THE SPACE AND CAPACITY TO
COLLECT BLOOD BUT CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW MUST FIRST LAY OUT
THE FRAMEWORK THAT BALANCES THE
INTERESTS AND WELL BEING OF
DONOR ANIMAL RECIPIENT ANIMALS
AND VETERINARIANS WHO NEED
ACCESS TO HEALTHY BLOOD SUPPLY.
I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT WE CAN
TRANSITION THEIR REMAINING
CLOSE CALL THE BLUFF THANKS THE
COMMUNITY MODEL COMMUNITY BLOOD
BANKS ARE SAFE ETHICAL
PRACTICAL AND BENEFICIAL TO THE
DONOR AND RECIPIENT AND THEIR
OWNERS I URGE YOU TO VOTE I ON
AB. TWELVE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK VERY MUCH. WE'VE
COMPLY OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE NOW OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT JUST SIMPLY BY STATING
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION IF
THEY WISH TO DO SO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE OF SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME S
NICHOLAS SOCKET SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
WATERLINE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JENNIFER APPEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU JUST ONE MOMENT. FIND
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH OR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF BEST
FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY AND ARE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS SUPPORTERS AND STAFF IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS SHANNON KEITH WITH
EAGLE FREEDOM PROJECT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES INTO FOUR PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEEN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
NOR IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. OPERATING
COMMITTEE ON HERE WHEN YOU
THINK IT. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE NO
DIGITAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS. OR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENIOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM DO WISH TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIMILAR BLOOM COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO BLOWN TO
PASTERNAK OR CULTURE LOW HIGH
LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA ALL RIGHT
BERMAN. BERMAN HI BLOOM HI LUME
ALL RIGHT CHEN. CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DALLI DELLY HI FONG
FONG ALL RIGHT GIPSON GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN IRWIN HI MCCARTY MEDINA.
MULLIN SALAS CHANGE. ELEVEN I
ZERO KNOWS LIVE IN ICE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SOME OF THEM. BECAUSE
WILL MOVE BACK TO FIGHT ORDER
THIS IS FILE IEM NUMBER NINE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FIFTY TWO BY SEVEN MEMBER WHAT
PLEASE FEEL FREE PERCENT
WHATEVER READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
EIGHT FIFTY TWO AS A FOLLOW UP
TO MY BILL LAST YEAR EIGHT BE
EIGHT NINETY WHICH CREATED A
PATHWAY FOR QUALIFIED. NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO PRACTICE
WITHOUT STANDARDIZED PROTOCOLS.
ONE SEED AB EIGHT NINETY BECAME
LAW IT WAS APPARENT THAT
MULTIPLE CODE SECTIONS
REFERENCING NURSE PRACTITIONERS
WOULD NEED TO BE UPDATED. TO
RECOGNIZE A NEW CATEGORIES OF
NURSE PRACTITIONERS.
DISPOSITIONAL EVEN AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF AB EIGHT NINETY
ISSUES REQUIRING CLARIFICATION
WERE BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION.
THE QUESTIONS PRIMARY WRITTEN
PRIMARILY RELATED TO SITUATIONS
WHEN NURSE PRACTITIONERS WOULD
CONSULT WITH PHYSICIANS VERSES
REFER TO POSITIONS. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING ALL COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THE AND
THE PHYSICIAN COMMUNITY TO
AGREE ON AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
REFERRAL PARAMETERS. PHYSICIAN
LIABILITY AND FURTHER REINFORCE
THAT NURSE PRACTITIONERS
CANNOT- HOLD THEMSELVES OUT AS
PHYSICIANS WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL CRISTY
WIESE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DR WORD. OPERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE LIMIT. YOUR COMMENTS NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING RESEARCH. AND MEMBERS
CRISTINA FOUND A HAPPY
CALIFORNIA. FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND THE COURT- WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND HELPING
OUT PASSED THE SIGNIFICANT
POLICY CHANGE LAST YEAR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH BB EIGHT
NINETY AND APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
THE SUPPORT. FOR THIS YEAR'S
CLEANUP BILL. AT THE DOCTOR
WOULD MENTION THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OTHER AREAS IN THE
CODE. THEY NEED TO BE UPDATED
TO REFLECT THE CHANGE IN NURSE
PRACTITIONER PRACTICE. AND
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD WE AFTER
ARRIVAL. EIGHTY VERY MUCH
OPERATIVE YOU PLEASE OF THE
LINES FOR A DISH MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WHICH IN THIS IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME SIMPLY NAY MAY
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IN LINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DON'T GET INTO
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
LOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF
MY NAME THE COLLEGE WITH
CONSPECIFIC A CENTERS FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES RIGHT
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE TWO IN ORDER TO TAKE
A QUICK MOMENT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP WITH AB EIGHT NINETY
LAST SESSION- THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RECTANGLE REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE MOMENT. FIVE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER
ADRIN SULTAN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE A CHILD A
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FIND SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLIP COPTER
ON BEHALF THE GOVERNMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. NINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WITH THE DOCTOR
MICHELLE HEATON ON BEHALF OF
CARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY TWO AM.
THANK YOU AND LINE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR- AND MEMBERS MATHIS M.
BAPTISTA YOU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. Q. M. LINE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN WORKING
WITH THE PHYSICIAN OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SENIOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE CHAMBER SO
OR IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION. ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
CURRENTLY HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
OR IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME I SEE WHAT MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC. WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS PLEASE FEEL
FREE PRESENT WHATEVER IT. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS EMILY HUGHES ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH US
ON THE CURRENT AMENDMENTS. AS
THE AUTHORS STATED AS AMENDMENT
AS AMENDED CIMI DOES REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS WHICH
ANY SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME CNN OPERATOR WILL MOVE ON
TO. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON
THE LINE COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF. FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TO CHEN NUMBERS BETWEEN
A RANSOM FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS.
THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED BY A
FAMILY MEMBER WENT VERY MOVING
OPPOSITION. EIGHTY EIGHT. IF I
CAN THINK MEMBER BLANCA THE
COMMITTEES AND THAT. IN THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN OPPOSITION TO
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR. NUMBER OF
CONVERSATION TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. SEE NOTE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DR
WOULD YOU WISH TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK VERY MUCH DOCTOR WOULD AS
YOU KNOW THE- OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF HAS BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY ON AN HOURLY BASIS
AND ON THE WEEKENDS ON A WEEKLY
BASIS AS WELL- KUDOS TO. OUR
COMMUNICANTS IN BITS AND SHE OF
WHO HAS BEEN IN CONSTANT
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AS WELL AS STAKEHOLDERS-
TO HELP ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
MOVING FORWARD O WITH THAT
THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB EIGHT FIVE TO WEAR TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
LOW HIGH LOW- HI FLORA. FLORA I
ARAMBULA. BERMAN BERMAN I
BLOOM. BLOOM HI CHEN. CHIU
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY HI FONG
FONG HI GIPSON- GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN IRWIN HI MCCARTY. MEDINA
MEDINA ALL RIGHT MULLIN. MULLIN
I SALAS. CHANGE. ELEVEN I ZERO
KNOWS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR WOULD A COLLEAGUES WILL
MOVE BACK INTO. FILE ORDER THEM
FOR MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THEN THAT BRINGS US THEN TO
FOLLOW MY THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON THIS DOES
ENJOY PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ONE THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR A MOVING THE
BILL VERY BRIEFLY HOW I THINK
IT'SCOMMITTEE FOR ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY
ONE WHICH WOULD CREATE A
PROCESS TO ENSURE CEMETERY
CARETAKERS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR NEGLIGENCE ABANDONMENT AND
FINANCIAL MISCONDUCT THIS BILL
IS PERSONAL TO ME BECAUSE OF
THE POOR CONDITIONS HAPPENING
AT THE WOODLAWN MEMORIAL
CEMETERY IN THE CITY OF COMPTON
AND I ALSO WONDER UNDERSCORE IS
WHERE I HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
ARE LAID TO REST- IT IS
HORRIFYING TO HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS LAID TO REST. IN A
CEMETERY- THAT IS DEPLORABLE
CONDITIONS- SUCH AS WOODLAWN
MEMORIAL CEMETERY THE CARETAKER
AT AT THAT TIME- WHO ABRUPTLY
SURRENDERED HIS LICENSE ON
JANUARY THE TWENTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. FAILED TO PROPERLY
FOLLOW CEMETERY MAINTENANCE
STANDARDS AND HAVE ISSUED
SEVERAL BEEN ISSUED SEVERAL
CITATIONS BY THE CEMETERY OF
FUNERAL BUREAU. ISSUES A
CITATION THAT INCLUDE AN
OPERABLE- IRRIGATION SYSTEM
THAT CAUSES THE CEMETERY- TO
HAVE WEEDS GROWING UP TO FIVE
FEET TALL- TOMBSTONES WERE
MISSING- INDIVIDUALS NAMES THE
GATES LOCKED OUT WHERE PEOPLE.
ARE WHO WITH THEIR LOVED ONES
CAN NOT HAVE ACCESS AND THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON MANY MAY
NOT KNOW THE WEIGHT LOSS IN
METAIRIE IS THE OLDEST CEMETERY
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. IT LATE
IT IT IT'S THE HOME OF
INDIVIDUAL EIGHTEEN CIVIL- AS
CIVIL WAR VETERANS THE FOUNDER
OF THE LOS ANGELES CHAPTER OF
THE BLACK PANTHERS AND A
FOUNDER OF THE CITY OF CARSON
AS WELL AS THE CITY OF COMPTON.
MEMBERS THIS BILL CENTERS
AROUND ACCOUNTABILITY AND HOPES
THAT EFFORTS TO PREVENT
CEMETERIES FROM FALLING INTO
DISREPAIR- AT TO- TO SHOW- IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE ALSO
HAVE THE CITY OF COMPTON WHO-
IS ON THE LINE- THE CITY
ATTORNEY- DAMON BROWN AS WELL
AS THE FOUNDER OF THE ONE
SECTION AT A TIME CELESTINA
BISHOP JACKSON WHO OF SELF
INTRODUCED. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON TO HOLD THE CEMETERIES
ACCOUNTABLE. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AMERICA. AND SAID THAT THEIR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHATEVER READY TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING SHARE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DAMOND BROWN I'M THE
CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF
COMPTON AND I AM PROUD TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S- HEARING
TO- LINDA SUPPORT OF CITY OF
COMPTON- AT THE FIRM BY THE
PASSAGE OF THE RESOLUTION
TWENTY FIVE OR THIRTY THREE ON
MARCH TWENTY THIRD TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE IS IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- THIS BILL
DIRECTLY ADDRESSES- THE STATE
OF THE LAW AS REGARDS PRIVATE
INVITATION CALIFORNIA THAT HAS
FOR SO LONG BEEN OUTDATED. AND
IT ADEQUATELY ACCOUNTED FOR THE
RIGHTS AND OBLIGATIONS OF THE
STATE PLANETARIUMS GENERAL
BURKE ZERO AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH RESPECT TO-
MIKEY CEMETERY FOLLOWING THE
REVOCATION OR SURRENDER OF
LICENSES ISSUED BY THE STATE
THE ASSEMBLY MAN HAS A VERY
THOROUGHLY GONE THROUGH SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT PLAGUE AT THE
WOODLAWN MEMORIAL PARK IN
COMPTON AND WE'RE SO EXCITED
THAT THE AREAS RELIEF ON THE
HORIZON BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
THE BILL INCREASES THE NET
PRICE FOR DEPOSITS INTO THE
ENDOWMENT CARE FUND. WHICH WILL
ALLOW FOR THE PROPER
CAPITALIZATION- THERE- TO
ENSURE PROPER MAINTENANCE OF
PRIVATELY OWNED CEMETERIES IN
PERPETUITY- IT PROVIDES FOR THE
APPLICANT OF THE COURT
APPOINTED TEMPORARY MANAGER
PUBLIC ACCESS AND MAINTENANCE
THE CEMETERY GROUNDS IN THE
EVENT THE LICENSE ISSUED THE
MANAGER OF A PRIVATE CEMETERY
IS REVOKED SUSPENDED OR
SURRENDER. AND IT AUTHORIZES
THE BUREAU TO COORDINATE AND
ASSIST OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH THEIR
INVESTIGATIONS AND OR CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS OF CEMETERY OWNERS
OPERATORS EMPLOYEES OR LICENSE
THE LIFE WHICH HAS BEEN
SUSPENDED REVOKED OR
SURRENDERED WHICH IS THE
PROPER- EXTENSION OF
JURISDICTION THAT THE BOARD
NEEDS TO REALLY REMEDY THE
PROBLEM SO AGAIN WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE THAT.
WILL BE OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
TO ALL HEALTH OR ANY INPUT INTO.
BOTH RESIDING IN THE OF COMPTON
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHER ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
QUESTION IS INTO. AT THEIR THE
UNDERSTAND THIS ADDITIONAL
PRIMARY WIN THIS PLEASE FEEL
FREE PRESENT WHENEVER READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SELECTING A BISHOP AND I
REPRESENT ONE SECTION AT A TIME
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
DEDICATED TO REACHED THE TO THE
RESTORATION OF NEGLECTED AND
ABANDONED CEMETERIES. WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING TO SAVE THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEAR OLD
HISTORIC WHAT MEMORIAL PARK IN
COMPTON CALIFORNIA. WHAT ONE
WAS MISMANAGED FOR DECADES
RESULTING IN MULTIPLE LAWSUITS
AND FINES. THE CURRENT OWNER-
CONTINUE TO MISMANAGEMENT LOT
FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS UP UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY. MAY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SECTION AT A TIME
BEGIN CLEARING CLEANINGS GIVES
ME THE CEMETERY. OF CHECK HI WE-
ANIMALS. THE LEGAL IN CATHOLIC.
WE HAVE WILL JERRY AND HI HIT.
FOR AND REPLACE. DAMAGED AND
STOLEN IRIGATION SYSTEM WITH
WE PROVIDER LIKE SERVICE. AND
WE HAVE BEEN MAINTAINING- ALIVE.
WHAT A SIZABLE DONATION FROM MY
HEAD AND MY STEP. OPEN THE GATE
TO THE PUBLIC AND WE ARE FULLY
STAFFED BY VOLUNTEERS PROVIDING
LOCATION SERVICES TO FAMILIES
THAT LOOKING FOR UNIFICATION
WHAT ON GATE HAS BEEN CLOSED
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS- PRIOR
TO TWENTY TWENTY. MOTHER EARTH
DAY IS THE FIRST DAY THAT ARE
GOING TO WORK ON I HOPPED OVER
THE GATE NOT CONNECTION WITH
WHAT LINE IS MY MOTHER AND MY
THREE SISTERS WERE- BLUDGEONED
TO DEATH IN A HOME WHEN I WAS
SO I'VE BEEN A- BIT THAT. ARE
OF WHAT LINE. MY SEVENTY. AT
TIME BECAUSE OF THE CAN- I
DECIDE TO CLEAN UP THE SIM CARE.
LIKE MYSELF AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY ALL RIGHT
FEDERATIONS LOOK UP ON VIDEO
CONTENT AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
WE WERE ABLE TO BRING DIGNITY
AND RESPECT BACK TO THE
CEMETERY I PRAY THAT. SB SIX
FIVE ONE- THAT IS REPRESENTED
AND INTRODUCED BY THE ARM
ASSEMBLY MANAGED TO GET SENT
WELL- HELLO THE FAMILY ARE WITH
THE GRIEVING WE ARE ALL
GUARANTEED TO BEING THAT LIFE
AND DEATH BIRTH AND DEATH. I
WANT TO FEEL SAFE AND SECURE IN
KNOWING THAT WHEN I TRANSITION.
I WILL BE PROTECTED A MILE TURN
ALAS THANK YOU. THE BUT. FIGURE
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WHICH IS BEGIN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME AGAIN JUST
NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. OVER A LINE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS THE
DESMOND WITH THE CEMETERY AND
MORTUARY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A WORKING
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
OPPOSITION ON THE MEASURE AND
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE EFFORT
THAT'S BEING MADE TO ADDRESS
THE WOODLAND THE SITUATION IN
COMPTON. A DEPLORABLE SITUATION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS THAT THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LINES AND SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEEN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS ARE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. WITH ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISH TO SPEAK N
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE UP
THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THERE
ARE NO LINES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS ARE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS EMAIL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON JEWISH TO CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOUR YOUR TO YOUR COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH MY- MY TEAM TO
MAKE THIS BILL I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS TODAY-
I JUST. ALSO WANTED SIMPLY SAY
THAT- WE CANNOT HAVE ON
CEMETERY OPERATORS WHEN THE
THOUGHT WHEN THE THINGS GET
TOUGH THEY JUST SURRENDERED A
LICENSE AND WALK AWAY THERE ARE
LOVED ONES WHO LAY THEIR RACKS
OF FAMILY MEMBERS AT
CEMETERIES. AND WE WANT TO
RESTORE DIGNITY RESPECT BACK TO
WOODLAWN CEMETERY I THINK THE
CITY ATTORNEY AND ALSO- MS
BISHOP JACKSON FOR STANDING UP
IN A LARGE WAY LET HER THEIR
VOICE TO BE HEARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BUILT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A MOTHER.
GIVES IN COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB SIX
FIVE GIPSON TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO A PROBE. LOW HIGH LOW HIGH
FLOOR. FLORA ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
HI BERMAN. BERMAN HI BLOOM.
BLOOM HI CHAN. CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI DALLI
DALLI HI FONG. FONG ALL RIGHT
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. IRWIN IRWIN
HI MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS.
SALAS I. EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN NINE
ZERO KNOWS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL MOVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. BECAUSE
WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN THIS IS THE
SECOND TO THE LAST BILL THAT WE
HAVE THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT BY
SIMILAR IRWIN WE DO. HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THAT PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT WHATEVER READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WILL
AUTHORIZE PHARMACISTS TO ENGAGE
IN PUBLIC HEALTH ACTIVITIES
LIKE HEALTH SCREENINGS AND
ALLOW THEM TO ADMINISTER. MANY
CLIA WAIVED TESTS I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US. AND I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
PHARMACISTS PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM. BY UTILIZING
THEIR EXPERTISE AND
ACCESSIBILITY TO. PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY PATIENT CARE WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT IS OVER TAXED IN A
RAPIDLY. AGING POPULATION THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE LIVE
WITHIN. FIVE MILES OF A
COMMUNITY BASED PHARMACY
HOWEVER PHARMACIST IN
CALIFORNIA ARE LIMITED IN THEIR
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES. AND TO
PROVIDE BASIC PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. THEY ARE NOT
CURRENTLY NOT. PERMITTED TO
PROVIDE MORE THAN A FEW OF THE
CLIA WAIVED TESTS EVEN THOUGH
THESE TESTS ARE DEFINED BY THE
FDA A SIMPLE TEST WITH A LOW
RISK. FOR AN INCORRECT RESULT.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
MINIMISES BARRIERS AND
RESTRICTIONS AND CURRENT LAW BY
PERMITTING PHARMACISTS TO
ADMINISTER CLIA WAIVED TESTS
WITH CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS. AND TO
NOTIFY THE PATIENT'S POSITION
OF ANY ABNORMAL RESULTS. IF THE
PATIENT DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION THE PHARMACIST WILL
PROVIDE THE PATIENT WITH A LIST
OF. PHYSICIANS CLINICS OR OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. ON THE
LINE WITH ME TODAY IS A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
PHARMACISTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
ME NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES. I
AM DR KEITH OF PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS. AND
ASSISTANT DEAN FOR
ADMINISTRATION OF TORY
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
OF PHARMACY. AND LYFT TO
PRACTICE LAW AND PHARMACY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS AND
HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN ORDERING
INTERPRETING LABORATORY TESTS
THE NINETEEN SIXTY. THE
PHARMACY CLINICS HAVE BEEN
ORDERING INTERPRETING LAUGHTER
IS THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTY.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE GRANTED
EVERY PHARMACIST IN THE STATE
OF FLORIDA ORDERED TO PROTEST
THE MONITOR FOR EFFICACY AND
TOXICITY OF DRUG THERAPY. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT THE
TECHNICIAN ALREADY BE ON DRUGS
JERRY. DRUG THERAPY TO ALLOW
PHARMACIES ENGAGE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH SCREENING. EARLY
DETECTION OF DISEASE MAKES
MANAGEMENT OF DISEASE EASIER
AND REDUCES MORBIDITY. IN THE
EVENT OF ABNORMAL RESULTS THE
PHARMACY WOULD DO IS WE
CURRENTLY DO WHEN WE ENCOUNTER
ABNORMAL BLOOD PRESSURE
READINGS WOULD REFER THE
PATIENT OR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER FOR A FOLLOW UP
DIAGNOSIS AND EVALUATION. ALSO
I STATUTES THE ONLY TAPPED THE
FARMS ARE ABLE PERFORMED AS
WELL SO WE ORDER. OUR TEST FOR
BLOOD SUGAR CHOLESTEROL AND
HEMOGLOBIN A. ONE C. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM BY EXECUTIVE ORDER
EXPANDED THE STOOPS INTO
CLINTON FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
COBIT VIRUS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT PERMITTED PROPERTIES TO
PERFORM ANY PLEA WAY TO WHICH
THE FDA AND DETERMINED ANY OF
LOCAL BLESSED HIDING. GIVEN THE
RELIABILITY. SEVERAL TO CLEAR
AWAY BECAUSE OF TO THE GENERAL.
WITHOUT A PUSH FROM USE BUT
PROVIDE. ARE REQUIRED TO OBTAIN
A LEVER LICENSE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
ORDER TO PERFORM THESE CLEAR
WITH TEST. THE MORE DESSERT
MAJORITY THESE CLEAN WAY TEST A
PHARMACY WILL CONTINUE TO BE
PERFORMED FOR THE MONITORING.
OF EFFICACY IN TEXAS TOXICITY
OF DRUG THERAPY. AND THEREFORE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING YOUR
AYE VOTE. ON EIGHTY THIRTY
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW MOBILE BONTA
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT ONLY.
PLEASE NAY MANIPULATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO OPERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WHAT IS A
LOT OF THE FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ONE
ZERO. I AM ONE OF THE LITTLE
FORMULA YEAH I VOTE. GOAHEAD.
I FORGOT THAT GOODMORNING MY
NAME IS DR ERIC IF I AM CHAIR
AND PROFESSOR OF CLINICAL PLAN
TO THAT SCHOOL UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF PHARMACY
AND THE CLINICAL PHARMACIST
SPECIALIZING IN DIABETES AND
CARDIOVASCULAR CARE AT KAISER
PERMANENTE HEY NOT NEW PRIMARY
CARE DEPARTMENT I HAVE A PANEL
OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED PATIENTS
WITH DIABETES OR CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE BY PRESCRIBING ADJUST
MEDICATIONS AS WELL AS
ROUTINELY ORDER INTERPRETING
MONICA LAB WORK NUMEROUS TIMES
EACH DAY DETERMINE HOW WALKING
FOR MY PATIENTS ARE WITH THEIR
CONDITION. AS WELL AS THE
TRIMMING THAT EIGHTEEN
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE MEDICATION
REGARDING PHARMACIST EDUCATION
IT IS IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT DOCTOR OF PHARMACY PROGRAM.
MOST COMMON CURRICULUM CONTENT
OF THREE YEARS OF CLASSROOM
TRAINING AND ONE YEAR CLERKSHIP.
THAT INCLUDES AMPLE CLINIC
HOSPITAL THEIR COMMUNITY
PHARMACY. THE PHARMACY
EDUCATION ACCREDITING BODY
REQUIRED THE CURRICULUM TO
COVER LAB DATA APPLICATION FOR
DISEASE STATE MANAGEMENT WHICH
INCLUDES SCREENING DIAGNOSIS
PROGRESSION AND TREATMENT
EVALUATION IN A CLASSROOM
SETTING STUDENTS LEARN THE
FOUNDATIONS ON HOW TO ORDER
INTERPRET AND MONITOR LAB WORK
WHEN THEY GO OUT ON THIRD SHIFT
STUDENTS GAIN HANDS ON
EXPERIENCE IN A CLINICAL
SETTING WITH MAIL LIGHT PATIENT.
REPORTING A LIKELY PHARMACIST
CALIFORNIA THE GRADUATE MUST
HAPPEN BOTH THE CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONAL LICENSING EXAMINATION
WHICH REQUIRE ENTRY LEVEL
PHARMACY. TO BE ABLE TO
PROPERLY OPTANE INTERPRET A
STAFF IN THE VALUATE LABORATORY
AND DIAGNOSTIC FINDINGS.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT SIMPLY ADD DEPARTMENT
THAT TO THE LIST OF OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
ABLE TO PERFORM CLEAR WAY PAST.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AYE VOTE
ON AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES OUR- OPPORTUNITY FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
GET A MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SIMPLY WISHING TO
SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT. BY
GIVING US THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. MY APOLOGIES THAT
WAS NINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE THANK YOU SORRY
ABOUT THAT THIS IS GOING TO GO
OVER TO THE CALGARY RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN DRUG
STORES THAT WE ARE BEFORE YEAH.
THANK YOU ONLY HAVE LINE SIX
TWO GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AND
MICHAEL HAWKINS ONE
REPRESENTING IN BE TODAY A OF
CLINICAL TESTING LABORATORY IN
SAN FRANCISCO THERE AND TRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES INTO
PORT PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL GOOD
THE WAY. SHE. OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. NO THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CENA ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS OR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
MORE NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHICH IS BEGIN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU CAN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND-
OKAY JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU A GREAT SENSE
ON HAPPY AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSED ON
THE MEASURE HOWEVER WE HAVE HAD
SEVERAL NEW HAVE HAD NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS DISCUSS OUR
CONCERNS AND HOPE TO CONTINUE
THAT DIALOGUE AT THE BUILDING
CORD. THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SEE NO DIGITAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
ARE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS
WISHING TO SPEAK. AND
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MEMBER MEMBERS ALRIGHT MISS
CALL. MATCH. OKAY THIS IS A
DOCTOR AND DIRECTOR I WOULD
SCHEDULE THAT THE WITNESS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION- I WAS NOT
CALLED AT THE TOP OF THE TICKET
THIS TIME. DID JUST TO CLARIFY
IT ARE YOU- HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ON ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. WHAT
OKAY I'M PLEDGES FOR MISS YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU- GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY%
NAME IS DOCTOR AND DIRECTOR AND
I'M THE MEDICAL AND CLEAR
DIRECTOR OF FIVE. THE LAND AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO INCLUDING
OVERSIGHT OF POINT OF CARE
TESTING. AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF PATHOLOGISTS.
PATHOLOGISTS ARE PHYSICIANS WHO
SPECIALIZE IN LABORATORY
MEDICINE ARE TYPICALLY
DIRECTORS OF CLINICAL AT THE
HOSPITAL. AND I WITH TO DATE
WITH ALL AND- OVER THE
PROVISION EIGHTY THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT AND YOU'RE OPPOSE
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL WEIGHT
FLAT PASSED WITH A PHARMACIST
MAY PROVIDE. HOWEVER WE
CURRENTLY ARE CLOSED UNLESS AND
THEN. OUR CONCERNS ARE WITH THE
BOY ARRAY OF WEEK CAST LAB AND
THEY'LL IT'S NOT THE PERFECT UP
THE CHECK. BUT THE PROF OF
ORDERING UNDERSTANDING THE
RESULTS AND ABILITY TO MANAGE
PATIENT CARE IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT. AS HIGHLIGHTED BY
A PASSER BY DEFINITION NOT
COMPLICATED TO PERFORM BUT THIS
DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE RESULTS
ARE NOT IMPORTANT IMPACTFUL ON
THE PATIENT PATIENT CARE. THIS
BILL TRANSITION OF PHARMACISTS
ABILITY TO PERFORM LAB TESTS
AND DRUG MONITORING FOR KNOWN
PATIENT KNOWN DRUG PRESCRIPTION
AND COLLABORATION ORDERING
PHYSICIAN. TWO EIGHT MUCH MORE
INDEPENDENT FUNCTIONING PAUL.
ARE WE HAVE TO PRESS INCLUDE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT AALYTES SPREAD
ACROSS EVEN IF THE COMPANY
DIVERSE CLINICAL SPECIALTIES
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
SENATE POLICY RENAL FUNCTION
LIVER FUNCTION CARDIAC FUNCTION
INFECTIOUS DISEASE FERTILITY
ANALYSIS. AND THE CHRONOLOGY
DRUG TESTING TOP EXPOSURE.
RESEARCH ACOSTA IN AN APOLOGY.
IN ADDITION AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT WHAT LAB TESTS PERFORMED
BY THE PATIENT. MAY NOT BE
NUMBER PROVIDED AND OUR CARES
CHALLENGING EVEN IN OUR CURRENT
CLINICAL LAB ENVIRONMENT. WAIT
NOT INCLUDING ON CRITICAL VALUE
IS THE RESULT WERE ARRANGED-
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE MEDICAL
ASSESSMENT POSSIBLE
INTERVENTION. NORMALLY GIVE A
CALL TO THE ORDERING PHYSICIAN.
EXPECTED THAT ELABORATE FABLESS
THE BALLOT. WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THE PHARMACIST HAS THE
KNOWLEDGE OR EXPERTISE SPORTS
BROADER WAY OF BRAVE TESTING
TYPE. ADDITIONALLY WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THE PHARMACIST IS
PROPERLY TRAINED TO ASSESS
PATIENT MEDICAL SITUATION IN
THE MOMENT AND A PROPERLY
DIRECTLY ACUITY A FOLLOW UP
MANY OF THE WAY TASK. WHICH
COULD HAVE CRITICAL VALUE. ARE
THE AMENDMENT PRESS ATTACHED
WITH BILL CONTAIN A LIST OF.
THAT COULD NOT BE PUT BY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT CONCLUDES
OUR TERM. DIRECTOR CLOSE THAT
CONCLUDES OUR TWO MINUTES. WE
WERE JUST GETTING A DIFFERENT-
OUTSIDE OF AMENDMENTS WHERE
THEY'VE PHARMACISTS WOULD LIFT
CONDITIONS WHICH WHICH THEY
COULD PERFORM COULD SCREEN
COULD MAKE REFERRALS AND THIS
IS BASED ON THE FLORIDA
STATUTE- THAT WAS ADOPTED LAST
YEAR. THANK YOU AND WE ARE
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING THE
DIALOGUE WITH THE SPONSOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. BUT THEN GO BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE NOTE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- WOULD YOU WISH
TO CLOSE YES- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR I WILL REPEAT
WHAT I HAD MENTIONED BEFORE A
CLEAR WAVE TESTS ARE TESTIFYING
BY THE FDA AS- SIMPLE TESTS
WITH A LOW RISK FOR AN
INCORRECT RESULTS. AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT EXPANSE PROXIMITY
TO CARE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL THE PARTIES TO
RESERVE. TO RESOLVE THE
CONCERNS ON THIS MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR IS ENJOYED DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION NUMBER SO
THE L. TWENTY SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT IRWIN TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA HI
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA ALRIGHT
BERMAN. BERMAN I BLOOM. BLOOM
HI CHAN. CHAN HI CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE DALLY
DALLY HI FONG. FONG HI GIPSON
GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON HI
HOLDEN IRWIN IRWIN HI MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS. SALAS HI
TEAM. SIXTEEN I ZERO KNOWS
SIXTEEN EYES BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A WIN.
COLLEAGUES WERE ON OUR FINAL
BILL PRESENTATION THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FOURTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER CARDI. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ON THIS BILL AB TEN
FOURTEEN A MEASURE TO HELP
CREATE PARITY FOR THE LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY- FIGHTING
AGAINST THE UNREGULATED MARKET
IN CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO- DELIVERY AT THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE BUREAU
BCC TO UPDATE ITS REGULATIONS
RELATED THE M. THE AMOUNT OF
PRODUCTS THAT DRIVERS CAN CARRY
IN THEIR- CARS AND CARGO VANS-
THE AMOUNT IN HERE I WILL SAY
WE DO HAVE A PENCIL THAT AMOUNT
BUT WE ARE OPEN TO NEGOTIATIONS
DEALING WITH. BEST PRACTICES
TALKING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
CITIES THE INDUSTRY AS WELL AS
DRIVERS- THAT THERE IS NO
OFFICIAL OPPOSITION- FROM THE
FROM THE DELIVERY FROM THE
DRIVER INDUSTRY BUT WE HAVE
RECEIVED SOME LETTERS AND SOME
COMMENTS FROM- THE LABOR UNIONS
REPRESENTING THE DRIVERS AS
WELL AS INDIVIDUAL DELIVERY
DRIVERS IN THE MARKET CONCERNED
ABOUT SECURITY ISSUES SO THIS
IS SOMETHING JUST AN EXCEL WE
WENT TO REMOVE BARRIERS AND
HELP THE LEGAL MARKET THRIVE
AND COUNTER- THE UNREGULATED
MARKET WE ALSO DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING THAT PUTS. DRIVER
SAFETY AT RISK SO AS THIS BILL
MOVES THROUGH COMMITTEE TODAY
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE DRIVERS THE FRONTLINE
DRIVERS TO MAKE SURE IT WORKS
FOR THEM WE DO NOT WANT TO PUT
ANYONE AT RISK AND IF IT IF IT
IT CAN'T BE ADDRESSED AND WE
WILL- ADDRESS YOU KNOW THE BILL
AT THAT TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT MAKES
SENSE FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
CONSUMERS. WHO MANY OF PEOPLE
LIVE SO FAR FROM A CITY THAT
HAS- ILLEGAL CANNABIS STORE SO
I HAVE TO FOCUS ON DELIVERY-
THIS BILL ALLOWS OUR BUREAU TO
UPDATE THE PROCESS AS FAR AS-
THE AMOUNT PER IN FOR- FOR
DELIVERY DRIVER IN THEIR CARS
IN THEIR- CARGO PANTS I WITH
THAT I HAVE A COUPLE WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE ASKING TO BE A
BRIEF BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
SUPPORTS A- THANK YOU ASK.
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
JUST A CLARIFICATION DISCARD
THE REPUBLICAN RECCO IS A NON
RECCO BUT THAT THANK YOU FOR
BRAVING NONE THE LESS WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. A
PRIMARY PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF IT WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TO LIMIT
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES FOR MEMBERS TO BE
SHOULD SPEAK IN SUPPORT AS
PROMISES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SHOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CLINT
OLIVIER I'M THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
BUSINESS FEDERATION AN
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING OVER
SEVENTY BUSINESSES AND
ORGANISATIONS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND SHARE. I WILL QUOTE
A LINE NUMBER NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS. FEEL ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COALITION
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN FOURTEEN
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND STAFF
FOR THEIR TIME SPEAKING WITH US
ABOUT OUR PERSPECTIVE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS EDDIE
FRANK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALSO SUPPORT AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING WITH
THE DOCTOR- HAD WITH THEM WAS
BARRED THANK YOU. NINE NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
YOUR REMEMBERS GRANT MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF CMG KHALIFA IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
EXCELLENT BILL THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M THERE CAN MEAN ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
SOCIAL EQUITY BRANDON
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTING AB TEN
FOURTEEN TO SAVE TIME WE ARE
NOT ALL PRESENTING HOWEVER I
WOULD LIKE TO READ THE NAMES OF
THE OTHER BRAND AND THE
COALITION SUPPORTING THEY ARE
BLACK STAR FARMS CLOUD NINE
JAMES HENRY YOUR UNT KGB
RESERVE OPEN EXTRACTS. NEW LIFE
SEE A NEW ERA BY A BIG GIRL
LIKE DEVELOPMENT GROUP LA
GRANDE TELOS SPECIAL BRANCH
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ERIC SKLAR AND THE CEO OF NAPA
VALLEY YOU MAY I'M AND I'M
SUPPORTER TEN FOURTEEN IT'S A
GREAT BILL THAT WILL BE AS GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND GOOD
FOR SAFETY AND THAT WILL HELP
INDUSTRY PPL LEGAL MARKET.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LINE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS TIFFANY
DEATH AND I REPRESENT CANNOT
CRAFT WERE BURKE VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CANNABIS COMPANY IN
SANTA ROSA WITH CLOSE TO THREE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AND WE AREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT AT THIS BATTLE.
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM WESLEY
HìNH ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
CANNABIS FOR CONSUMER SAFETY
COALITION TO SAVE TIME I'M
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF OUR
COALITION MEMBERS WHICH INCLUDE
TAX CANNOT SAY FLAPS MAMMOTH
DISTRIBUTION MARIJUANA POLICY
PROJECT AND ANOTHER FIFTY TWO
POOR GONNA STATIONS IN OUR
COALITION WHO SUPPORT AT TEN
FOR TEN. THANK YOU. K. LINE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANNY CORRAL- FROM LAU TAK VICE
PRESIDENT REPRESENTING FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN EMPLOYEES
IN SUPPORT OF AB AND. FOURTEEN
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. S.
DISABLED VETERANS LIVING IN
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA. AT. I AM
NOT SURE WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT
LINE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN. SORRY HELLO MY NAME IS
TONY BOWLS AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF PATIENTS I AM A CHAIR
OF THE BAY AREA CHAPTER OF
AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS. WE
ARE THE NATION'S LARGEST
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS TO ENSURE SICK PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR CANNABIS
IS MEDICINE. CALIFORNIA HAVE A
LONG IMPORTANT HISTORY
PROTECTING ASIAN ACCESS
BEGINNING WITH PROP TWO
FIFTEEN. EIGHTY TEN FOURTEEN IS
AN IMPORTANT BILL TO CONTINUE
TO ADVANCE THE VISION OF
MEDICAL CANNABIS ACCESS. IT
WILL HELP HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIA TO RELY ON
CANNABIS MEDICINE TO ATTRACT.
HEALTH PROBLEMS RANGING FROM
CANCER TO HIV INFECTION SHE TO
RACK. THANK CREATING THE AMOUNT
OF PRODUCT A DELIVERY VEHICLE
TO CARRY. EIGHTY TEN FOURTEEN
WILL HAVE A DIRECT AND POSITIVE
IMPACT ON PATIENT ACCESS.
DELIVERY OF A GOD SENT TO
MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENTS WHY
MANY PATIENTS HAVE MOBILITY
CHALLENGES ARE LACK ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION. WHICH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT OR IMPOSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO TRAVEL TO BRICK AND
MORTAR STORES. A LOT OF THAT
60% OF CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE
MORE THAN AN HOUR FROM
ELECTIONS CANADA STORE. NOW WE
CODED DELIVERY ADDS ANOTHER
LAYER OF PROTECTION FOR
PATIENTS. JUST LIKE GROCERIES
HOME GOODS PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATION. DELIVERY ACT THAT
THE CANDIDATE AT THE DOORSTEP
SIMPLY SAFER. ALLOWING FOR
INCREASED LIMITED DELIVERY
VEHICLES WILL ALLOW FOR A
SINGLE DRIVER TO REACH MORE
PATIENTS AND CUSTOMERS IN ONE
TRIP. THIS WILL REDUCE DELIVERY
TIMES AND GIVE PATIENTS
RESIDING FAR AWAY FROM A
LICENSED RETAIL STORE FRENCH
MORE ACTIVE THAN BEFORE.
FINALLY IT WILL HELP PATIENTS
GET THEIR HANDS ON STATE HAS
BEEN CANADA'S FROM THE ILLEGAL
MARKET. RIGHT NOW PATIENTS IN
MUCH OF THE STATE THEY'LL HAVE
TO BUY FROM. AND LICENSE OR-
SOURCES. HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA
MAR. NO EVIDENCE THAT LEGAL CAN
THE VERY I'D SAY. ON THE
CONTRARY DATA DELIVERY TO BE.
AND CONVINCE THEM WAY FOR ADULT
CAL FIVE EAGLES JANET. A FACT
REINFORCED BY HOME BILL CAN.
HAS ESSENTIAL CODE STAND ORDERS
EXPLAINING THAT ARE JUST THE
BILL ON FOR TWENTY IN LIGHT OF
THE DAY IN THE WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS I
RESPECTFULLY AFTER THE WAR AB
TEN FOURTEEN. THE YOU VERY MUCH
I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT WAS THEY
AUTHORS PRIMARY WITNESS.
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. YES LINE
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YET YOUR
MEMBERS- THAT MORALLY NUMBER
DIRECTOR COMPLIANCE AND
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS WE KEEP A
COMPACTION I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF CUBA AND A COALITION OF
MIGHT BE CANNABIS BUSINESS
INCLUDING QUIET REFLECTIVE
GRANT AND NUMBER AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FOURTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
LINE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING WHICH JOBS
OUT THERE WITHIN THESE
TECHNOLOGIES- IN STRONG SUPPORT
AB TEN FOURTEEN THEIR
REASONABLE PIECE OF LEGISLATION
TO PROVIDE ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL MY NAME
IS JANE VICTOR I AM THE CEO AND
CO FOUNDER OF JAMES HENRY OUT
OF YOUR SOCIAL EQUITY LICENSED
CANNABIS COMPANY BASED IN THE
BAY AREA THAT MANUFACTURES
PRODUCTS. FOCUSED ON RESPONSE
ONE THERAPEUTIC USE WE ARE IN
BLACK AND US VETERAN OWNED.
MANY BLACK ENTREPRENEUR LIKE ME
ARE NOT CANNABIS RETAILERS ALL
WE WORK IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN INCLUDING
MANUFACTURING AND CULTIVATION.
WE CREATE JOBS WE PAY TAXES WE
ARE REQUIRED TO CALIFORNIA'S
LEGAL MARKET MARKET. I OFTEN
HEAR ALEXA FISHEL STRESSED THE
IMPORTANCE OF SOCIAL EQUITY AND
ADDRESSING THE WAR ON DRUGS.
RIGHT SIX FRAMEWORK. AND IT
SHOULD MAKE YOUR JOB SIMPLE TOP
BLOGS THAT HELP BY POP. REACH
CUSTOMER AND SELL OUR PRODUCTS.
AB TEN FOURTEEN A DRUG WITH
VARIANTS BY POPULAR THE LIMIT
ON THE AMOUNT OF. TIME IN THE
CANNABIS NICKEL CURRENTLY GOT
LIMITED MOLD OR WEEKS THE
SERVICE NOT. THE WITH THE COLD
AIR. THE FORTY THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN DELIVERY MINUTES WORK
BACK AT A TOTAL OF TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS THEN THAT NUMBER WAS
REDUCED BY HALF. THE LIMIT IS
NOW FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. THAT
MAY SOUND LIKE A LOT OF
CANDIDATES BUT IT'S NOT LIKE HE
CANNABIS PRODUCTS ARE EXPENSIVE
SO THIS IS A VERY SMALL BODY.
THE FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR LIMIT.
MEANS THAT I CAN TELL BLESSED
CANNABIS WATCH WHAT THE EQUITY
PRODUCT BY THE LIVERY AND IT
ALSO MEANS LESS TAXES WITH
THIRTY. DELIVERS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT WAYS I REACH
CUSTOMERS AND DELIVERY DEMAND
AT DODD ROCKETED IN THE LAST
YEAR HOWEVER THE CURRENT FIVE
THOUSAND. LIMIT MAKES IT HARDER
FOR SMALL BRANDS LIKE MINE. AND
MEET THE CUSTOMER DEMAND BIGGER
BETTER FUNDED GRANT HAVE A HUGE
ADVANTAGE THIS IS THE VERY
DEFINITION OF IN EQUITY. YOU
CAN HELP BY POP COMPANIES BY
RETURNING THE DELIVERY BUT- TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. ONLY INVITE
REPORT SUPPORTS THIS MOST OF
THE HIGHER CANNABIS COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS THAT PATIENT REPORTED.
PLEASE DO YOUR PART HOPE THE
BUSINESSES LIKE MINE AND PEOPLE
LIKE ME PROPERTY GROW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOURTEEN
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR VICTOR THAT CONCLUDES
OUR SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OPERATOR OTHER
ADDITIONAL CALLERS ON THE LINE
TO SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT. YES
LINE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY WILL MOVE TO
THE NEXT FINE LINE STEP ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME IS HARRY
BEREZIN I'M WITH- PLEASE FARMS
WHERE A LICENSED CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTOR IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE REPRESENTING THIRTY ONE
EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT OF AB AND
FOURTEEN THANKS VERY MUCH.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINE
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SCENE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING THE
CHAMBERS AND THE COMMITTEE
ROOMS WHICH HAS BEGIN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME WILL OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
NINE ZERO. MORNING IT UP WE
JUST A MOMENT. IS THAT LINE.
ONE SEVENTEEN. GOOD MORNING I'M
UP I'LL BE A PRIMARY ARE. I
THANK ALL YOUR WITNESS THANK
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JONATHAN
CIRCLING THE WRECKAGE AFTER
UNITED CAN WITH THE
DISASSOCIATION. CAN WITH
BUSINESS LOCATION REGRETS TO
INFORM YOU THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TEN FOURTEEN I'M NOT
COMMENDED. THE PRIMARY
MOTIVATION OF THIS BILL IS
LISTED AND COMBATING THE
ILLICIT MARKET WE COMMEND THE
AUTHOR'S INTENTION HOWEVER WE
DISAGREE THAT THE CURRENT BILL
LANGUAGE MEANING FLEE COMBAT
WITH THE MARKET. ADDITIONALLY
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT AB TEN
FOURTEEN. HAS UNINTENDED.
SERIOUS RISK CONCERNS- IN OF
TWENTY TWENTY- A CALIFORNIA
JUDGE HAS ISSUED THEIR RULING
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DID IN
FACT HAVE THE RIGHTS TO
PROHIBIT OUTSIDE CANNABIS
DELIVERY SERVICES. FAIL TO SEE
HOW INCREASING THE INVENTORY
LIMIT COMBAT THE ILLICIT MARKET
ACCOUNT WITH DELIVERY SERVICE
CANNOT LEGALLY ENTER THE
JURISDICTION TO BEGIN WITH. IN
ORDER TO MITIGATE THE INHERENT
SECURITY RISKS THE CANNABIS
DELIVERY DRIVERS. RESPONSIBLE
MAXIMUM INVENTORY RATE HAS BEEN
DISPATCHED TO THE CURRENT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. DELIVERY
VEHICLES. DO NOT HAVE THE SAME
SECURITY PROTOCOLS IN PLACE.
THAT ILLEGAL CANNABIS
STOREFRONT THAT. SUCH AS A
SECURITY GUARD NINETY DAYS THE
SECURITY CAMERA FOOTAGE AND
MANY MORE. INCREASING THAT
LIMIT FIVE TIMES TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS MAY ONLY SERVE
TO INCENTIVIZE THE ROBBERIES OR
WORSE HARMS TO CANNABIS
DELIVERY DRIVERS. WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THE NECESSARY TO
KEEP SECURITY NEEDS IT WOULD
NOT BE RESPONSIBLE TO INCREASE
INVENTORY LET. THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL ONLY
ACHIEVE THE ALLOWANCE OF HIGH
RISK MOBILE DISPENSARIES. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A LIKE A PIPE
FOR RETAIL THAT RESPONSIBLY
ALLOW ACTORS WERE LARGE
QUANTITIES OF INVENTORY CAN BE
HEALTHY BUT- HI TEN STOREFRONT
CANNABIS RETAILERS. YOU SEE A
THEATER AND WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR ON ADDRESSING
THE CONCERNS IN ORDER TO
PROMOTE SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE
PRACTICES. USED TO BE A
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SECOND PRIMARY
WINNERS IN OPPOSITION. J.
HEARING OPRAH SECOND PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. RECORD OF
LINE OF. ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AM CHARGE
YOUR NUMBER BECAUSE OF THE
REPORTERS I ACTUALLY GET A
CHANCE. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
SORRY HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
WE WERE AT THE LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE GIVING TESTIMONY SO
I'M HERE TO REPRESENTATION
ABBASI GROUP. THAT WENT IN A
SUPPORT LETTER TO AB TEN
FOURTEEN. THESE COMPANIES THAT
THEIR NAMES BE READ IN SUPPORT
AS WELL. OPERATION ME BACK. BAY
AREA AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS.
SAN DIEGO AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS. SAN FRANCISCO BRANDING
MERRY DEMOCRATIC CLUB
CALIFORNIA NORMAL INVESTORS
CANNABIS COALITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. NINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
JENNY JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO CANNABIS
RETAILERS ALLIANCE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TEN
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE MOMENT. NINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NO
RESPONSE FROM NINE THIRTY FOUR
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENIOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS ARE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I SEE NO QUESTION THE
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARD TO DO WAS TO CLOSE THANK
YOU AYE I ASKED FOR THE SUPPORT
OF MY- COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY
BUT JUST ALSO WANT TO REITERATE
THAT TIME WILLING TO WORK WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS A TWO FOLD TO-
FRANKLY THREE FALL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE INCREASE ACCESS FOR
CONSUMERS OF A LEGAL PRODUCT-
TO MAKE SURE WE REMOVE
BARRIERS- FOR ILLEGAL
OPERATORS- WHO ARE WORKING
REALLY HARD. IN AN AREA WHERE
WE HAVE SO MUCH I'M REGULATED
OPERATORS WHO ARE CUTTING INTO
THEIR- LIVELIHOOD IN THEIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES AND THEN
THIRDLY WE ALSO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IT IS SAFE AND
MAKES SENSE FOR DRIVERS SO.
WE'LL WORK WITH- ALL PARTIES AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS ON
THAT LAST PIECE THANK YOU SB
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
JUST TO GIVEN THE SUBJECT
MATTER ASSEMBLY MCCARTY. GIVEN
THE SUBJECT MATTER HOW HOW DO
YOU PLAN ON RECOGNIZING THIS
AUSPICIOUS DAY OF FOR TWENTY.
I'LL TAKE THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TEN FOURTEEN MCCARTY TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW-
HI FLORA- FLOOR I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BERMAN BERMAN HI
BLOOM. BLOOM HI CHEN CHEN HI Q.
CHIU HI CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
AYE DALY DALY IPHONE. GIPSON
GIPSON HI GRAYSON GRAYSON HI
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. HI
IRWIN HI MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA MEDINA HI MULLIN- WHEN I
SALAS. TAKING TEN HI. SEVENTY
NINE ZERO KNOWS THAT HAS
SEVENTEEN HIGHS HIS. I BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUE WILL GO BACK INTO
FILE ORDER. AND. WE'LL BEGIN
THEN WITH. THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB TWO EIGHT SEVEN QUIRK AB
FOUR SIX TWO CARILLO AB FOUR
SEVEN ONE LOW AB FIVE OH ONE
CRISTINA GARCIA AB TEN FIFTEEN
BLANCA RUBIO AB TWELVE TWENTY
TWO CHEN TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI CHIU CHIU HI
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. IRWIN
HI MCCARTY MCCARTY HI MULLIN.
MULLIN I SALAS SALAS EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN HI. NINETEEN AYE
ZERONOS. NINETY NINE THAT IS
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SIX
NINETY ONE BY SIMILAR CHAO. SB
SIX NINETY ONE CHILD TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI CHU. CHU I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. IRWIN
HI MCCARTY MCCARTY HI MULLIN
MULLIN I SALAS SALAS HI TEAM
TEAM HI. NINETEEN AYE ZERONOS.
THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SIXTY NINE BY SOMEONE
PATTERSON THIS DOES ENJOY
CHAIRS. RECCO OF SUPPORT. AB
TWO SIX NINE PATTERSON TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
AMBULANCE HI QIU QIU I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI MULLIN. MULLIN I
SALAS. SALAS I EIGHTEEN TEAM HI.
NINETEEN AYE ZERONOS NINETEEN
IS THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB FOUR NINETY TWO
BY SOMEONE PATTERSON DOES ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. AB
FOUR NINETEEN PATTER FOUR NINE
TWO PATTERSON TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHU. CHU HI
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
HOLDEN. HOLDEN HI MULLIN.
MULLIN I SALAS SALAS HI TEN TEN
HI. NINETEEN AYE ZERONOS
NINETEEN IS THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TEN
TWENTY SIX BY SEVEN MEMBERS MET.
AB TEN TWENTY SIX MATH TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHU. CHU HI
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI MULLIN. MULLIN I
SALAS SALAS HI TEAM TEAM HI.
NINETY NINE ZERO KNOWS.
NINETEEN IS THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOULD. AB EIGHT FIVE TWO WOULD
YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHIO. CHIU I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI. THIRTY THIRTY HI
SALAS SALAS HI TEAM TEN HI.
SEVENTEEN ARE ZERO KNOWS
SEVENTEEN IS THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TEN
THIRTY FOUR BY SUMMER BLOOM. AB
TEN THIRTY FOUR BLOOM DO PASS
CHIU. CHIU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HI HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN. IRWIN I MCCARTY MCCARTY
HI MULLIN. MULLIN I SALAS. KING
KING HI. IRWIN NOW. TWELVE FIVE
ONE NOW PROVIDES THAT BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO BY SUMMER
BLOOM. AB TWELVE EIGHTY TO
BLOOM TO PASS TO AGRICULTURE
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM. TWO I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA. MULLIN.
MULLIN I SALAS SALAS I EIGHTEEN
KING HI. SEVENTEEN AYE ZERONOS
SEVENTEEN EYES THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB
SIX FIFTY ONE BY SUMMER GIPSON.
AB SIX FIFTY ONE GIPSON TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
QIU. CHU HI HOLDEN HOLDEN HI
TEAM TEAM HI. NINETEEN AYE
ZERONOS NINETEEN IS THE BILL
WITHOUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY SAM A WOMAN OR IN. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT IRWIN TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS QIU. QIU HI
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI TEAM TEAM HI.
NINETEEN AYE ZERONOS. SHOULD.
OKAY OKAY. NINETEEN ZERO
NINETEEN EYES THE BILL IS OUT
AND THAT WAS AGAIN SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT THE BILL WITHOUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN A. B.
TEN FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY. AB TEN FOURTEEN
MCCARTY DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND ALL MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN CALLED SEVENTEEN EYES
ZERO KNOWS. SEVENTEEN ICE THE
BILL WITHOUT. OF AND THEN WILL-
DOUBLE. RESECTABLE GO BACK TO A
CONSENT. YOU'RE GOING. YEAH
YOU'RE OKAY. AB TWO EIGHT SEVEN
QUIRK AB FOUR SIX TWO CARILLO
AB FOUR SEVEN ONE LOW EIGHTY
FIVE OH ONE CRISTINA GARCIA AB
TEN FIFTEEN BLANCA RUBIO AB
TWELVE TWENTY TWO CHEN TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU
THIS BILL. HELLO AND THEN LETS
GO OF A CONSIDER BUT WE CAN GO
BACK TO. LET'S SEE. FIRST
ORDERS GO BACK TO ASSEMBLY A
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY FOUR-
MISTER WHEN. THEY'RE WORKING
WITH. TWELVE AYE ZERONOS. AND
THE MAN OF HIS SECRETARY BACK
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO WITH MR
MEDINA. AB TWELVE EIGHTY TO
BLOOM TO PASS TO AGRICULTURE.
MEDINA MEDINA HI. EIGHTY NINE
ZERO KNOWS EIGHTEEN ICE. BILLS
OUT. K. THAT CONCLUDES ALL OF
THE BILL PRESENTATION AND ALL
OF OUR VOTES THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING THANK YOU.